it's been a month
i'm sorry at least memes should be good
[Music]
travis scott apology video that should
be rockstar's apology video as well same
one you rockstar you know what this
shouldn't be called rockstar you should
be called
i can't say it because i'll get the
monetized but you can figure out the
rest when you post a meme and someone
said man this subject's become garbage
yeah that's read it for you everything
just always used to be better man i
remember back in the day i remember
pewdiepie and philip shelburne yelling
at jackets
autumn he's always there and he always
has my back isn't that right focus there
you go
nice
we both hate jacksepticeye isn't that
right
he's this yes
i'm dark pewdiepie there we go i'm
bright pink in 1897 three fleets
attempted to be the first people to
reach the north pole hot air balloon got
cold and crashed after 68 hours 33 years
later a ship discovered their camp along
with their dead bodies journal and
camera they'd survived for weeks by
killing and eating polar bears
bro it took 33 years to come and save
them
god yeah
imagine they survived for 33 years
i got a shotgun
i mean
for 33 years really no one else could
have gone and checked on the swedes
that's [ __ ] youtube will remove
dislike from their videos meaning only
the person who uploads the video will be
able to see dislikes farewell to this
legendary video in this video get the
same amount of likes as dislikes i can't
believe they actually went forward with
it i thought for sure since so many
creators uh raised their concern and and
uh
yeah i'm surprised they actually did it
it's kind of messed up i was wondering
about this where are the other 108
million people 510 million subscribers
35 understanding but only around 2
million people watching video no
well to be afraid of that video did kind
of poorly but hey i mean if i got 110
million viewers on every video
thank you that'd be amazing
sadly that's not the case for anyone
this channel is hyperinflated with
subscribers because of all the t-series
and blah blah blah and ironically i
never even wanted subscribers to begin
with but hey here we go i did say like i
considered myself retired like a year
ago and i'm just kind of doing videos
for fun and you know
not to
pat myself on the back but i think we do
have like a good variety we get cooking
videos philosophy videos
stupid crap videos talking about random
stuff videos going out in public videos
collab videos drama videos gaming videos
but reading all the comments here
everyone's like
he's only doing reaction videos i can't
believe it that's why i'm not i'm just
like bruh everyone's always just trying
to put me in a box like before i did
reddit videos a lot and then i was like
he only does reddit videos it sucks now
i think people always do that and it's
getting really tired some it's like guys
i'm just trying to have fun
i wish he was the person he was five
years ago okay people change
let me grow up like what it's the same
in like even back in the day like people
always go he i he used to make horror
videos now he only plays happy wheels
like i'm not allowed to change kind of
but
i think the truth is like naturally the
first time we engage with something is
going to be the most fun and exciting
and i think since i've done videos for
such a long time people associate me
when they first discovered me that's
what was going to be the high for people
and i think people they project that
positive feeling not being there anymore
onto me and being like you've changed
it's like bruh it's normal chill i'm
just chilling homie god damn don't ruin
the vibe all right just trying to chill
man come on too long didn't let's send
reddit as being super whiny and uh
you need to stop it's
dumb you're dumb not me it's not my
fault you're dumb uh how the tables turn
on poor edgar he demands a lot of
attention he won't let him sleep he
demands a lot of attention he wants
yeah
yeah that's what you get edgar idiot
edgar's the kind of guy that says i
prefer edgy pewdiepie
get cringe grow the [ __ ] up edgar uh
along with youtube and youtube kids
there should be youtube adults where
swearing and the dislike button are
allowed advertisers can then choose
which platform to push their ads on this
guy's freaking genius put this one in
the great ideas that will never be
implemented for whatever reason we will
never understand
five six me after finding out people are
breaking their legs to get taller oh my
god that's disgusting where
oh yeah i remember that this is almost a
month ago video that's funny
i can't believe it people are doing that
that's horrible anyway where do i sign
up youtube hiding the dislike can
dislike right
that's just going to be the new i was
actually thinking about this like
youtube said that they're they're
changing dislikes to stop creator
harassment that's their main reason look
at the most disliked videos it's really
youtube rewind
baby shark come basically my point here
company company company company
basically i mean company company kids
kids video kid video kid video kid video
me let's go
jake paul call of duty company coco
melon coconut coconut coconut cocoa
melon cocoa melon damn is that a cocoa
melon conspiracy here netflix sesame
street my point is i don't believe it i
don't believe it at all
since fifth in italy we dare have to eat
pizza in a restaurant i did this i don't
know if it's up yet uh i kind of wanted
to i look forward to the memes on it
i had to survive a bear attack if it's
brown laid down if it's black fight back
i love this i love this so much because
i was thinking it like you need an acro
and it's not an acronym but you need
some way to remind and remember it
that's so good and then i read another
one that said if it's white good night
that's so good it already existed i knew
it basically i am so smart thank you i
wonder if pewdiepie talks to himself
like this even when the camera isn't
recording
two years ago felix said top comment
wins xbox yet i wasn't rewarded xbox i
just need everyone to know my pain oh
it's coming definitely don't worry about
it and also if you like and subscribe in
this video you could win an xbox as well
oh and refresh the video a bunch of
times so it looks like it has more views
because uh people are complaining that i
don't get enough views so thank you
thanks for doing that he's hiding what
travis scott failed
hey
you're right
can we get someone to talk about
yeah
[Music]
that's the thing like the artist sees it
that's great huge props to jj for doing
that big peepee huge respect like how
could you possibly like keep performing
i know he was probably high out of his
mind but damn man there were even more
victims that passed away in like
young kids we shouldn't have been there
in the first place but still just that's
such a tragedy man dude saying that
finland isn't a country finland that
fought side by side with swedes for 600
years and who defended sweden soviets in
world war ii and we were still a buffer
between sweden and russia i'm sorry
finland
it's a joke
did you think you did all this stuff huh
you can't even take a joke [ __ ] [ __ ]
i'm joking there you go hey
come on
uh watching naruto random kid hey that's
the skin from what
hey that's the pewdiepie skin that's
what they're talking about it's cg
behind the scenes it's actually cg huh
that's so cool though they actually put
like a ton of cgi into a youtube video
that's kind of nuts like bruh how am i
supposed to compete with that
five add some cool cgi what the dog do
that's the best freaking day no it's
impressive i like huge respect for mr
biggs and what he does i just want to do
youtube the way i've always done youtube
which is me and a camera in a room
talking [ __ ] that to me is what's fun
about youtube it's with the beard dudes
with the mustache i miss pewdiepie when
he had a beard he was
he was more beardy than i like did thank
you it was like chill cause you all
right
unless you're a suite in the north pole
what about kanye west sink i actually
really like it it's a very aesthetically
pleasing sink and you can tell the water
is actually diffused which makes it
splatter less they probably have like an
uh a metal grid uh so that the water uh
tension i don't know what's called in
english it doesn't break and splatter so
it's purposely made so that it fizzles
out it's all in detail no one cares
about the details anymore everyone just
want this stupid the c943
chinese sink mass produced
shazam is really good i thought it would
abandon your country the secret
ingredient is crime the secret in
ingredient is nordvp oh it literally
said it this movie was sponsored by
nerdy pian ken told me can you believe
this ken told me he got nordvpn because
he needed it but he didn't use the
pewdiepie link what an idiot you got to
use the link
there's no code anymore there's a link
he's delaying goddamn you get bonus
average pewdiepie highlights in jurian
subscribe to pewdiepie highlights i
prefer pewdiepie highlights over
pewdiepie at this point random guy
coming in dislike on fake videos
creators after deleting the comments wow
that's so weird it just disappeared
wow
he's watching his fandom
no bro it's weird as cringy as his
tattoo is it is probably my cringiest
tattoo and if there's any
uh when i should reconsider it's
probably that one but i do love it it's
one of my favorite and especially now
that it has this fortnight sentimental
value uh hi i repurposed one of my old
projects for uh pewdiepie so i hope he
enjoys
sweden
[Applause]
in norwegians
they're using science now
small peepee actually why do i feel like
i could smell it
did you feel that too
that was me
just wait until you see the pizza video
oh i can't wait to see everyone getting
pissed off can we take a moment and
appreciate tunes for the effort he put
into the thumbnail yeah that was not my
proudest video
so i thought hey i'll put all my i'll
put all my effort into
oh god i listen
i'm so embarrassed by that video it's so
sh it's reacting
listen i was going on a day trip here in
italy i needed a video so i was like hey
you can just record this i'm like you
know what that's what we're doing and lo
and behold it's my most viewed video in
a while
oh god you know what the inverted people
are right you know i take it all back
this sucks
why did mr felix put a half eaten cookie
back in the pan so i can eat it later
god damn i know marta didn't like those
why would i people got so mad at me for
looking at the calories i saw people
were like the nutritional value is way
more important felix but i'm like from
eating thanks
[ __ ] you talking about nutritional value
for i get the counting calories is can
be le something toxic and just
something people obsess over but i just
want to get an idea when you're eating
something real unhealthy just like how
bad it is right i don't know that's me
you want to quit alcohol just quit bro
such helpful words you're welcome listen
i know this sounds insane to say but i
at least like to think
that you can be the person you want to
be or do the things that you want to do
by just simply doing them
that's having that sort of power at
least it's ironic how like most
self-help philosophy can boil down to
a nike t-shirt that says just do it and
on the back it says no pain no gain
that's what it all comes down to
basically
[Laughter]
i'm so excited to read the comments on
bing bang drill tag tag bang felix
what's going on hey you have to face the
powerpoint might see it sinks are
overrated
oh i remove the sink with here
oh that's great love that i love the
style too blank straw again coming out
with a big peepee amazing i love edgar
too so cute
i was actually thinking like i know this
might sound stupid in a practical way
but like everyone uses the sink as a
dishwasher right everyone just puts it
in there why can't the sink be the
dishwasher
right
it's how we intuitively put things we
don't intuitively just like slime it in
there couldn't it be some way to make
the sink a dishwasher that's a billion
dollar idea you're welcome reddit yeah
that was for free this guy now watching
playthroughs of poppy playtime there is
one thing that immediately stands out
everyone high fives huggy high five high
five buddy
apparently there's just some sort of
primal reflex in our monkey brains
raised hand equals high five
let's go a computer
don't get jealous but uh
hey computer
don't be jealous yes
i like that all right well thanks for
watching this we uh monday we
go subscribe to win a billion no wait i
said that wrong i said the one subscribe
and you could win a billion
and i'll see you guys next time
motherflappers until then profess